[Musik]
ich muss bringen eine aktivität
gesetzlich nicht so viel darüber
in baden vor jetzt entscheiden wer von
einer 5 wird diplomaten oder diplomat
[Musik]
erste station weg zettel auf deutsch
diplomatie ist in der schweiz nicht
besonders beliebt man kennt muss wenn
das ist vielleicht schon auf sie zählen
wird für die nächsten jahrzehnte
[Musik]
mitgliedsstaaten
ich wollte früher im hotel christina
kontrolliert normaler ablauf für die
woche lang geschafft
140 staats und regierungschefs der
uno-vollversammlung streng vertraulich
samira musik den vortrag hatte sie
gottes mal auf die neue residenz vor der
schweizer botschaft im vortrag geht zum
verantwortungsvolles wirtschaften chefs
von schweizer firmen abschlussprüfung
also das ist natürlich nach zusatz end
wo haut ja grundsätzlich maja ist
ausgelaugt aber mal stand bis
wirtschaftstreffen fort
[Musik]
aber der bischof
weil sie
[Musik]
okay es war dessen habe aber durch die
aktionäre und soll
[Musik]
worden
wenn's
der fahrer der samira wird nicht gewählt
werden und dann machte den
entscheidenden fehler
er fragt ausgerechnet polizei nach dem
richtigen weg und vergisst dass thommy
thematisch freilosen polizei und kommune
schlacht die kombination das kind länger
[Musik]
jean baptiste joly 15 teams in zwei
tagen sind der präsidentschaftswahlen
am meeting lucky star alonso mit
[Musik]
noch ein bisschen gehen in einem in
einem großen hotel du schon bist hätten
wichtige aufgaben als offizieller
beobachter für das muss er eine
informations alles für die europäische
union
was hat einem treffer passiert die
streng geheim
filme gott um nicht der transfer zum uno
hauptgebäude christina schmitz mit
string
die aufgabe dass der bundespräsident
immer zur richtigen zeit am richtigen
ort ist
[Musik]
maximal dürfen
das war's
speak english im service perfekt wie
sich auch sehr gut aufgegangen
[Musik]
ein bundespräsident auf dem trottoir das
bild ging um die welt vorbereitet hat
sich der online börse da übrigens oft
uno-generalversammlung drastischer der
schweiz russe minister im jahr zu gast
waren tritt von bundespräsident an einem
bergsee muss christina der teleprompter
bedienen problem vor journalisten
grossartiges wieder sehr gut ihre
inhalte oder weniger gerettet
[Musik]
die größte user fordere ich die
intellektuelle energie die pp duelle die
ewige intellektuelle neugier alicia sich
mit total neuen team müssen
auseinandersetzung mit fremden kulturen
mit fremden sicht wiesen oder und sich
jan jetzt verschließe um langsam die
meinung vertreten müssen sie besser
scrolls wieder absolut gar nichts und
dann von der botschaft
[Musik]
es heißt es ja irgendwie sachen
eingebunden
[Musik]
es sind wichtige helfer vor grosse
schweizer firmen musste mir aber jetzt
erzähle was verantwortungsvolle
geschäftsführung bedeutet und warum das
wichtig ist und dann wird sie schon
diplomatisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wirtschaft
ria novosti
rohrbeck
[Musik]
sonntagmorgens new york christina die
arbeitskollegen zum bremsklotz der
christina applegate sind aus schweizer
und alle schritte schweizer mission grün
schaffte mit amerikaner sind keine
entstanden
die erste kompakte aber wie kam es dass
für die fans wirklich genau da etwas ist
was ich mir für bagdad sind aberglaube
außer beschäftigt sind
das amerikanische schiff wie im umfeld
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
und jetzt wird wald spielerisch befreit
diplomaten ins labor lang auf der ganzen
welt unterwegs
vor der schweiz bin spiele ich und
gruppe aufs thema heimat das klima und
wie sehr ich mich sowieso nicht so stand
ich das hotel ist auch lisa freundlich
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
samira auf die ausbildung 100 prozent
für familie machen
[Gelächter]
nach argentinien wo alte unschöne
erinnerungen wach werden
das land am rio de la plata steckt wie
vor um 20 jahren schon einmal in einer
gefährlichen währungskrise bin jonas 21
30 darum jetzt vieles um die
wirtschaftskrise der eurocity aufgaben
politische bricht verfasser führt
regierung in bern dass in argentinien
passiert hätte ein direktes wort krieg
auftritts wie sie botschaft ist ähnlich
wie eine antenne wo die einzelnen
entwicklungen detektiert was man
vielleicht von den verschiedensten ist
ja mehr mit dem säbel sei sich aber sehr
wichtig ist es möglich ganze palette von
sts
eine strafe von politikern und
wirtschaftsführern
besonders interessierte jonas was die
frau verzerrt präsidentin der
aussenpolitischen kommission vor
spannende präsentation fragt darf ich
noch einmal ganz herzlich und damit
trage ich mit will man wo sehen sie das
größte potenzial von argentinien für die
nächsten zehn jahre bei den menschen
ich glaube die sind gut wenn wir an die
menschen denken und wenn wir uns kommt
mit ihrer und ich glaube das ist
wirklich gut aber wir müssen auch etwas
barmherzigkeit da an den mann ganz egal
wie und womit die nächste
[Musik]
die größte herausforderung ist dass man
wirklich relevante informationen gewinnt
also wieso tag wird oft begrenzt aber
wenn ich sehe dass irgendwie sehr
wichtig dass man die lücke abholen oder
dazu bringen dass sie ob das bett hüten
zu sagen wofür mit personen relevant ist
quasi als interessanter als das glas und
stelle war wenn ich das wüsste
da bleibt ja
[Musik]
was war noch ob kommen ihr büro ließ den
präsidentschaftswahlen im senegal
fast sieben millionen senegalesischen
tut ihr die stimme ob favorit ist der
aktuelle präsident max an
jean baptist und seine arbeitskollegin
vor der botschaft sind also beobachte
meine wahl mehrfach durch erfahrung ist
vielleicht 15 minuten lang aber es gibt
ganz ganz ganz viele sachen
wir haben so ein formularen mit
kriterien fragen müssen das ausfüllen
werden denn dann ist das material dar
wer ist im raum vechta im raum kommen
oder nicht und wir müssen wie
integrieren
wir müssen einfach beobachten
wir müssen auch aufpassen das ist keine
polizei im büro gibt ist nicht erlaubt
das ist es was die linie probieren
aber schon im nächsten wahllokal stimmte
bis nicht so ganz
ist auch nicht drin sein
das geht in report der eu wo die wolle
bewacht
er hat gesagt solange es vielleicht noch
am anfang so und so lange die nicht in
die büros kommen ist nicht so schlimm
sein
in senegal wird der alte präsident wohl
auch der neue sein mag i sal
der 57 jährige gilt bei der
präsidentenwahl als großer favorit sei
dürfte davon profitieren dass senegal in
den letzten jahren einen beachtlichen
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung erlebte
sind wir schon mal besser
[Musik]
hallo
und wenn du gegen
kampeter
[Musik]
das ist natürlich die krone oder drei
jungs die ganze politische situation
einem jahr studiert die wahlen und ganz
die walbeobachtung an kasse stimme
sinnlos zelt couvert mit resultat für
sie glück
aber nach drei stunden fertig jetzt
münze zum rapport zu der botschafterin
hallo chefin habe ich habe auch etwas
gegen aber ich hab jetzt ein bisschen
also immer noch mitgefiebert
ich weiß nicht wie du das ich hatte ein
mikro micro tages auch nicht makros ist
wie wenn du ein news anschauen oder
twittern das war wirklich alles mikro
oder die vielen gibt es dann weißt du
deine keine blätter als spannend die
stimmung reißt du mit den menschen in
kontakt zu sein
die schweizer botschaft schrieb der
jonas ihm bricht mit allen informationen
gesammelt hat als studierte physiker als
diplomaten eher untypische hintergrund
ja wirklich sehr gerne und ich im moment
bin ihre weise ums leben und mehr geld
das paar situationen
am anfang ist man da vielleicht noch wie
ich habe das nicht ganz so bequem aber
damit nicht genug und weiß dass man
eigentlich auch an improvisieren muss
[Musik]
große staaten die auktion ihr das nicht
aus dass zudem hier gut
[Musik]
diesmal bin ich überzeugt ja da war ich
wirklich
und dieses gefühl am richtigen ort zum
richtigen zeitpunkt zu sein ist einfach
wahnsinn und dass das hat das ist
wirklich ein f kenntnis von diesem
diesem jahren
[Applaus]
wenn ich mir selbst ich habe man dank
starke wichtig ist sollten inhalt und ja
also dann kriegt gewiss eine situation
im land weiter sicher gut wenn man es
als auch und auf eine bestimmte art der
aber auf eine art ist irgendwie auch
nicht
[Musik]
er musste
die letzte ausgabe
[Musik]
dinge die diplomatische karriere nach
wie vor extrem spaß macht man mit dem
countryman ist auch unglaublich dass man
das machen muss aber das kino highlight
die hörte man findet hyp die groß
schluss prüfstand
zwei jahre diplom autos bildete kongos
diplomatique das alles können die hütt
plötzlich radio
[Musik]
doch gleich los
ich habe mich vorbereitet die brauche es
nebst ökologisch die symbolik ist stark
[Musik]
moment ich glaube es gab genau denn im
moment darum dass man sich am ruhigen
und eine ganze nervösen wirke vor der
kommission
die kommission sieht hochrangige
diplomaten unter dem motto karriere dass
ich eigentlich für das hat sich neun
städten also in dem sinne es ist ein
letzter kontrollblick wo man wirklich
sich sofort sieht das nach den zwei
jahre probezeit dass die wirklich die
bedingungen erfülle 25 gehört dazu
diese freigrenzen vorstandes dann dein
bachchor diese zwei jahren so zu
verteidigen und ich finde dass frau
kraft da passiert was
[Musik]
das ist dort war ja jetzt ist das
ähnlich nicht erreicht
die kommissionsmitglieder kritische
fragen stellen sagt jetzt mal das sind
spannende fragen und frau warum haben
sich immer noch lieben muss aber wir
haben wirklich erlebt hätten zwei jahren
was war die größte überraschung die sie
über sich selbst erfahren haben im
senegal
wow und da hab ich ich hatte ich hatte
ich hatte keine ahnung ich musste ein
bisschen etwas fertig sein
doch eigentlich kein kritische frage die
frage gibt es eine gute antwort also da
bin ich froh vor deinem hat ja jetzt
innerhalb weniger stunden entscheidet
kommission werde häufig besteht
und wer diplomatin oder diplomat
[Musik]
bitte die leute werden älter ist und
ich werde jetzt sorgen gehen ähnlich
das habe ich so vermisst ich habe ihn
seit er klein jogging machen weil die
luftverschmutzung war für mich so
schlimm
und jetzt endlich nach einer nach
halbjahr nicht einen tropfen an die aare
machen und das ist wirklich ich freue
mich wenn sie beim volksentscheid
[Musik]
carlos simon wittmann
da
das
es ist pause
[Musik]
sehr wohl
als gregor gysi
[Musik]
teheran zu erhöhen
der alex und samira hand also bestand
aber wie es der andere trug komme
[Musik]
die leuten sollen diplomübergabe vom
minister im jahr zu gast
höchstpersönlich
[Musik]
melina seien sie ganz herzlich
willkommen und sie reißt die serie
einstellen
[Musik]
seien sie herzlich willkommen zum
etappenziel entschuldigung und in den
diplomatischen korps schweiz zwölf nie
diplomatinnen und diplomaten
preisblasen der beton soll die musik
[Musik]
er ist
es kommt alles
[Musik]
ja er hat zurzeit
ich sage nicht gefragt
[Musik]